bien sting est ce que vous êtes prêts
pour un hardi view vous pensez à quoi en
ce moment la vie à votre prochain invité
quand vous vous regardez dans la glace
le matin vous vous dites quoi
je vois mon père de plus en plus et il
te dis quoi ton père dans la glace je
lui dis mais jusqu'au 5 août est mort
mais sinon je suis pas mort vous auriez
aimé ressembler à qui quand vous étiez
petits jeux comme bonjour ressemble à
mon père voilà votre plus belle histoire
d'amour c'est laquelle l'histoire de mon
épouse trudie quand avez vous pleuré
pour la dernière fois
entendez la musique est plus rythmé un
jeu plus facilement c'est un des grands
talents vous changeriez quoi en vous si
vous aviez une baguette magique au moins
d'argent peut-être à gauche à radio web
j'aimerais bien avoir votre esprit assez
gentil
kelly clichy qui vous tente le plus donc
fighting sexe bâtisse bad
non non vous voulez ce n'est pas propre
qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire de plus
négatif sur vous si votre vie était à
refaire qu'est-ce que vous changeriez
rien n'est calé l'insultent qui vous a
fait le plus mal
ah ouais nature bien sûr lorsqu'elle est
vrai ça fait mal prête je vais pas mal
et me confesser à blogging les hobbits
la caprice à nha trang peut que feriez
vous s'il ne vous restait que 24 heures
à vivre mais claf faire l'amour safe sex
and en 24 heures il a fait l'amour avec
sa femme pendant huit heures une fois
émoi 12 heures est atteint
singh avez vous déjà pensé à vous
suicider parce que quand ça va trop bien
comme ça jamais non j'aime trop la vie
pour penser à ça ah il est arrivé julio
iglesias